hey what is up everybody it's animac
here for anime uproar and as we all know
the devil fruit that Luffy possessed
since the very first chapter of the
story The gomugomunomi turned out to be
something completely different we can
assume that the original Joy boy was a
user of this legendary devil fruit and
800 years later Monkey D Luffy became
the second known user but what if I told
you that we already know a third user of
this devil fruit that we've known them
since chapter 550 of the manga and that
the hitohitonomi model Nika is closely
connected to the truth behind the will
of D and the D Clan there is a lot to
talk about so let's go you guys know how
this works if you enjoy our videos and
you want to see more in the future leave
a quick like and comment right now it
only takes you a second but it really
helps with that YouTube algorithm and if
you're new to anime outpro or maybe you
just haven't taken the time to subscribe
yet yet do me a quick favor and make
this the video that you subscribe and
hit that notification Bell to turn on
all notifications before we get into it
big thank you to path to Nowhere for
sponsoring this video path to Nowhere is
a brand new Sci-Fi RPG with an extremely
unique Mysterious World which integrates
superpowers gang culture the Cthulhu
Mythos and so much more into a dark
gritty and stimulating experience the
game combines real-time Tower Defense
gameplay with top tier strategy and a
novel prison and crime theme you are the
leader of a crisis control Bureau and
you use special abilities to control
dangerous and Charming Sinners beings
who are infused with superpower each
Center character has their own unique
powers and abilities and as their powers
grow and their desire to do good
increases you can decide whether you
want to seek their salvation I
especially like Ariel she looks so cute
and yet so dangerous at the same time I
just need to learn more about her path
to Nowhere stands out from other games
because of its dark gritty and sexy
style and the artwork is truly distinct
and captivating it provides an immersive
gameplay experience with dozens of story
stages puzzle games and challenging
roguelike mechanics tactics and strategy
are crucial for winning and the player's
skills on the battlefield are critical
for Success download path to Nowhere
right now and get in on the gritty and
stimulating Adventure just click that
top link down in the description and use
my gift code to get special rewards in
game
finally this video will contain One
Piece manga spoilers so please proceed
with caution you have been warned joyboy
was first introduced in chapter 628 and
then much later in chapter 1018 we were
introduced to the legend of the sun god
Nika as soon as both of these characters
were mentioned in the story The
one-piece fandom began speculating that
there is some connection between Luffy
and either Joy boy Nika or both fans
were theorizing that Luffy could be The
Reincarnation of Joy boy or that Joy boy
was a special ability that is somehow
passed down for centuries kind of like
Poseidon or that Joy boy might be Luffy
who traveled back in time and so on
similarly as soon as we learned about
sun god Nika the protector of all those
who are mistreated and enslaved fans
began comparing his silhouette to the
silhouette of Luffy dancing in Sky Pia
and so on so yeah the speculation was
definitely there but when the truth was
finally revealed it still shook the
fandom and caused an absolute explosion
of hype as we now know Luffy's devil
fruit is not really a paramecia type
devil fruit called the gomugomunomi its
true name is the hitohitonomi model Nika
and it is actually a mythical Zone devil
fruit or mythical zolon whichever
pronunciation you prefer when Luffy
undergoes his devil fruit Awakening
during his battle with kaido his heart
which had actually stopped beating for a
while started beating again with a
strange Rhythm a rhythm that zunesha
refers to as the drums of Liberation
zonesha also confirms that Luffy's devil
food Awakening The Awakening of the Nika
devil fruit also constitutes the return
of Joy boy and so this confirms that
Luffy is in some ways both Joy boy and
sanganika although we're still not quite
sure what exactly this means it is
possible that sun god Nika is just just
a legend that emerged because the
previous user of the Nika devil fruit
the historical Joy boy was himself a
liberator and a hero to those who were
imprisoned and enslaved and so maybe the
only real link between Joy boy Luffy and
Nika is the devil fruit itself Luffy is
not a God or reincarnation or anything
like that he just happened to inherit
the same devil fruit that Joy boy
possessed a devil fruit that is already
associated with a Godly hero of
Liberation and Luffy is just now taking
on that mantle but there may be more to
this story as I've argued in multiple
other videos here on the channel in fact
in one video I theorized that once a
user of a specific devil fruit dies some
of their lineage Factor remains inside
the devil fruit and is then passed on to
Future users of that fruit this means
that Luffy possesses some of the
original joyboy's lineage factor and
this might account for some of Luffy's
similarities to Joy boy as well as some
of Luffy's as of yet unexplained powers
and abilities I won't go into that here
because there's a lot to talk about but
I will link that video in the
description if you want to check it out
the point is that we're still not 100
sure about the true nature of the
connection between Luffy droyboy and
Nika but we do know that they are
certainly all connected through the
hitohito no me model Nika but what was
going on with this overpowered mythical
Zone devil fruit in the 800 years
between the time that joyboy possessed
it and the time that Luffy consumed it
in chapter 1 of the story the world
government has known about this fruit
for a long time and in fact they have
been attempting to get a hold of it for
Generations unfortunately for them they
were never able to get their hands on it
and even when they got close the devil
fruit would always slip out of their
grasp this has led the gorosei to
conclude that the Nika fruit has a will
of its own and that it has been actively
resisting the world government's
attempts to capture it how exactly was a
devil fruit able to do this isn't clear
just yet but it has been said that zolon
devil fruits in particular seem to have
a strong will of their own and we now
know that the Nika devil fruit is
actually a mythical Zone however for the
longest time everyone believed that
Luffy's devil fruit was called the
gomugomonomi and that it was a paramecia
type devil fruit that gave its users
body the properties of rubber turning
him or her into a rubber human that is
because over the centuries the world
government realized something unless the
Nika devil fruit undergoes an outright
Awakening as was the case with Luffy
during his fight with kaido it will
basically just act like a paramecia type
rubber devil fruit it will give its
users body the properties of rubber and
that's basically it and since this is
all that the devil fruit has done for 8
centuries it had never awakened for all
that time the world government simply
changed all of its historical records in
order to alter the Nika devil fruits
name and classification anyone who came
across it would think that this fruit is
called the gomogomunomi and that it
turned its user's body into rubber no
one would know that this was actually a
Godly mythical Zone devil fruit with
Incredible powers and with an important
historical significance the world
government was hoping that if they can't
take the fruit for themselves then they
can at least hide its true power and
potential which would of course make it
less likely that the world government's
enemies could use the fruit's power
against them after all how can you go
out of your way to obtain this fruit and
awaken its true power if you don't know
what it really is or what its true power
actually entails but all of this makes
it clear that there were other users of
the gomugomonomi between Joy boy and
Luffy how would the godo say no that
unless it awakens the Nika fruit will
act as a paramecia type rubber-based
devil fruit they knew it because there
have been other users and the godose
were able to gather information about
those users the gorosei noticed that
Nika's true power simply wasn't
Awakening like it did with joy boy
during the void century and every time
another user would consume it it would
simply act as a paramecia-esque
rubber-based devil fruit when the user
died the fruit would reincarnate and the
process would be repeated this happened
for so long that the world government
seemed to have gotten used to it and
since Nika hadn't awakened in eight
centuries they didn't seem too worried
about it they kind of let their guard
down and so when they heard that a young
pirate from the East blue named Luffy
obtained a fruit that matches the
description of the Nika devil fruit they
didn't really worry too much about it
and they didn't go out of their way to
eliminate him at least not at first
after all the fruit has been passed
around for eight centuries and it never
became a threat so why would this time
be any different well as we all know
this time was certainly very different
and the world government is now
regretting its complacency but I am here
to tell you that just three years before
the birth of Luffy there was another
living user of the Nika fruit although
back then it was still just the
unawakened
gomogomunomi that person is none other
than the mother of Luffy's bro Ace and
the lover of the former pirate king
Goldie Roger I am of course talking
about podcast D Rouge unfortunately we
know very little about Rouge herself but
the one big thing that we do know about
her the one event that defines her as a
character is the key to unlocking the
secrets of the Nika devil fruit before
it ended up with Luffy Goldie Roger knew
that he was dying long before he
willingly gave himself up to the Marines
and so he had plenty of time to make
preparations for his epic final act the
very act which brought about a new
golden age of piracy one of the things
Roger did before giving himself up was
to leave his lover podcast the Rouge
with child and Rouge is believed to have
been about five months pregnant at the
time of Roger's execution because Cipher
pole somehow found out that Roger was
expect affecting a child the world
government forces attempted to find the
child they didn't want the only living
heir of the Legendary Pirate King to
challenge the world government in the
future and so they were determined to
eliminate the child before it ever had
the chance to become a threat the world
government did the math and they looked
for a child that could have been born
within nine months of Roger's execution
however they never could find Roger's
son and there is a very specific reason
for that Roger's pregnant lover Rouge
was living on the island of batarila in
the South blue as the world government
searched for hers and Rogers unborn
child and yes for you Spanish speakers
you can also pronounce it batteria or
baterija now in order to divert all
suspicion away from her son Ace Rouge
somehow managed to stay pregnant for 20
months instead of the normal 9 months
since this shouldn't even be possible
the world government was fooled and they
didn't take case away because they
didn't think that he could possibly be
Roger's son the math just didn't add up
when Ace was finally born Rouge secretly
named him gold dies in honor of his
father but soon after giving birth she
died because her body couldn't survive
the strain of a 20-month pregnancy after
rouge's death Ace was taken in by Monkey
D GARP who ultimately placed Ace in the
care of curly the Don Ace would later
change his name in honor of his mother
who sacrificed her life to give birth to
him and so he became podcast D Ace and
of course it didn't hurt that podcast
was a far less Infamous surname than
goal which was the surname of the pirate
king himself this part about Rouge and
her extraordinary pregnancy goes by very
quickly in the story and we never really
got to know much more about Rouge at
least not yet and I think that most fans
just kind of gave this crazy 20-month
pregnancy a pass because hey one piece
is a Fantastical story where a lot of
crazy stuff happens and the world of one
piece is clearly different from our own
world so who knows maybe a 20 month
pregnancy really is possible in that
world except Oda made it clear that
something like this shouldn't have been
possible not even in that world and the
very reason why the world government was
successfully tricked is because they
could never have believed that any woman
could remain pregnant for 20 months it
was just unheard of even in the world of
one piece and personally I always felt
that something was a bit off about this
situation in our own world doctors
normally never allow a pregnancy to go
on for more than a week or two beyond
the nine month due date and that's
because allowing a pregnancy to go for
longer poses a health risk for both the
mother and the baby the first and most
obvious issue is that the baby is
continuing to grow and it will
eventually become too big for the
mother's body to accommodate there is
also a risk that the baby will be
compressed to such an extent that it
will no longer be able to get the oxygen
it needs to survive I won't go into all
the Gory
but suffice it to say that a healthy
20-month pregnancy is absolutely
positively impossible for a human being
to endure I did some research because I
was curious and the longest pregnancy
that resulted in a healthy birth appears
to have been just over 12 months this
pregnancy which occurred in 1945 seems
to have been well documented and
verified there have been women who claim
to have been pregnant for longer even as
long as 17 months but these claims have
not been verified and doctors are highly
skeptical that this is possible as far
as I've been able to find no one has
even tried to claim that they have been
pregnant for 20 months verified or
unverified so with that in mind we have
to consider the possibility that rouge's
20-month pregnancy wasn't achieved
through normal means we have to consider
the possibility that she had some sort
of Supernatural ability that allowed her
to do this and what better ability to
achieve this than a devil fruit that
gives your body the properties of rub
rubber a devil fruit that allows you to
stretch your insides at will enabling
your body to accommodate even a massive
20 month old baby thanks to Luffy's
gears we know that even the unawakened
gomugomunomi can be used to manipulate
the blood flow and oxygen circulation
within the user's body so this would
also explain how Rouge was able to keep
her baby alive under such extreme
conditions so if Rouge was really a user
of the gomugomonomi it is possible that
the devil fruit's body manipulation
abilities would allow both Rouge and her
baby to survive a 20-month pregnancy but
if Rouge really could accomplish all of
this then why did she die after giving
birth why didn't the gomugomonomi allow
her to Simply give birth and move on
like nothing happened well we have to
remember what an incredible ordeal it
would have been for Rouge to keep using
the devil fruits abilities constantly
for such a long period of time we know
how exhausted Luffy becomes when he
overuses his gears and how much recovery
time he usually needs in the past some
characters like Rob Lucci have even
speculated that using his gear Powers is
draining Luffy's life force and that it
could be reducing his lifespan so even
though Rouge wasn't like using Gear 3 or
gear 4 in battle she was still using her
power non-stop for months and months in
order to keep her baby alive long past
his due date and that would have taken a
terrible toll on her even someone with a
rubber body still has vital organs that
can't just be pushed beyond their limits
endlessly at some point they are going
to give out rubber or no rubber and that
seems to be what happened with Rouge she
pushed her pregnancy to 20 months in
order to save her son and while the
gomugomonomi allowed her to do that
physically the effort also took a
massive toll on her body her organs
couldn't take it anymore and soon after
giving birth she died after her death
the gomogomunomi was of course
reincarnated somewhere else and it was
eventually located and captured by
forces loyal to the world government but
the forces Royal to the world government
couldn't keep the fruit for long because
it was stolen by the red-haired Pirates
and taken to fuchsia village where it
was consumed by a young Luffy so the
timeline makes sense and just from a
narrative perspective the idea that
there have been other gobu gomonomi
users over the past 800 Years also makes
sense when the gorosei said that the
Nika devil fruit has a will of its own
and that it has seemingly actively
avoided them I'm sure they didn't mean
that the fruit literally bounces away
from the Marines and escapes them every
time they try to capture it the gorosei
were saying that every time they are
about to capture the devil fruit it
seems to find a new user and that user
takes it out of their grass the Nika
devil fruit may not have awakened in the
centuries between Joy boy and Luffy but
that doesn't mean that it wasn't used in
all that time now even though I came to
the Rouge is a former gomungomunomi user
theory on my own when I was doing
research for this video I noticed that
multiple people have had similar
theories for years even before the Nika
devil fruit reveal so I'm definitely not
the first person to think of this and I
can't take credit for that but I do
think that the Nika reveal adds a new
dimension to this Theory and the
significance of the Nika devil fruit and
its will the fact that it's somehow
willingly avoids capture by the world
government brings me to the secret
connection between the Nika fruit the
will of thee and the D Clan clearly
Luffy is a member of the d-clan and of
course Rouge is the only known female
member in the entire series if we accept
a theory that Rouge possessed the
gomugomonomi then that would mean that
two of its known users were members of
the d-clan which is a pretty massive
coincidence since there are only 10
known d-clan members in the entire
series a series which features over a
thousand different characters and that's
before we take into account the popular
theory that the third known user of this
devil fruit Joy boy was also a member of
the D Clan but the truth is that joyboy
didn't have to be a member of the d-clan
himself because he could actually be the
progenitor of the D Clan there is a
popular Theory out there that d-clan
members are actually the descendants of
the rulers of the ancient Kingdom those
who fought against the world government
800 years ago Joy boy was likely the
leader or one of the leaders of this
ancient faction now of course this
faction lost the conflict from 800 years
ago the world government was eventually
formed and once that happened the world
government erased all historical
knowledge about the ancient Kingdom and
the war that they fought against the
world government after that the rulers
of the various kingdoms that formed the
world government moved to marijua and
became the celestial dragons but there
is an interesting theory that the d-clan
are descendants of the original
Celestial dragons the ones who ruled the
ancient Kingdom before their positions
were usurped by the world government and
the new Celestial dragons in fact the
letter D May literally stand for the
word dragon and it is there to serve as
a constant reminder that the current
Celestial dragons are nothing but
usurpers and this is exactly why members
of the d-clan are considered to be the
natural enemies of the gods they they
are the natural enemies of the world
Nobles because they are the true World
Nobles they are the rightful rulers of
the world and so their very existence is
an existential threat to the power of
the Celestial Dragon the infamous will
of D may actually be the will to write
the historical wrong committed by the
world government during the ancient war
or the alliance that eventually became
the world government the will of D could
be the will to restore the true
Celestial dragons to their rightful
place and banish the false dragons from
their usurped positions of power some
members of the D Clan want to achieve
this through force and deception like
zebek and Blackbeard While others like
dragon and Luffy want to achieve it by
bringing the world together and
overthrowing the tyrannical World
Government but whether it is conscious
or unconscious the will of D leads all
members of the D Clan to defy the world
government in their own way many of them
oppose the world government directly
like Roger Dragon zebic Blackbeard law
Ace and Luffy but others may even work
under the world government as was the
case with Saul and GARP but think about
it even those members of the D Clan who
ended up joining the Marines like Saul
and GARP did defy the world government
in certain moments of critical
importance
Saul abandoned the Marines and decided
to help Robin at the cost of his own
life and GARP secretly helped to protect
both Ace and Luffy despite the fact that
their fathers were literally the most
wanted criminals in the world and that
brings us back to Rouge a woman who did
what should have been literally
impossible in order to defy the world
government and deny them the opportunity
to hurt her son so every d-clan member
has defied the world government and the
celestial dragons in some important way
this is what they all have in common and
this could be the secret of the d-clan
whose Origins can be traced all the way
back to Joy boy and the ancient Kingdom
so the Nika devil fruit The Godly fruit
which has a will of its own may also be
subject to the will of Thee the Nika
fruit may also gravitate towards members
of the d-clan because they are directly
connected to the fruits of original user
joyboard the will of D could be part of
the reason why the Nika fruit has
managed to avoid capture by the world
government for so long the Nika devil
fruit could be connected to members of
the D Clan and it is possible that it
naturally gravitates to them and away
from the world government and the
celestial dragons if so then it would
make sense that the only two users we
know after Joy boy have been Rouge and
Luffy two members of the D Clan and if
this theory is in fact true then it also
leaves us with a very dark future for
One Piece after all Blackbeard is also a
member of the D Clan and he has the
ability to steal devil fruits therefore
if the Nika devil fruit gravitates
towards members of the d-clan Blackbeard
may attempt to steal this incredible
devil fruit from Luffy sometime in the
future the epic showdown between Luffy
and Blackbeard is inevitable but based
the one we know about the will of thee
thus far once their Showdown finally
begins both Luffy's life and his devil
fruit could be on the line now that we
are in the final Saga of the 1p story
things are really heating up like never
before and I can't wait to see what
happens next let me know what you guys
think do you agree with me that podcast
di Rouge was a user of the gomugomonomi
also known as the unawakened Nika devil
fruit also is the Nika devil fruit
connected to the will of thee and what
is the true meaning behind the D Clan
what is the common thread between all of
its members is it their common instinct
to defy the world government don't
forget to leave your thoughts down in
the comments below if you guys enjoyed
this one piece video and you want to see
more in the future leave a quick like
and comment it really helps a lot and if
you haven't taken the time to subscribe
yet remember that it's completely free
and it does a lot to help help on
YouTube you can also hit me up on
Twitter and Instagram at anime uproar
thanks again to path to Nowhere for
sponsoring this video check them out
Link in the description as always thank
you guys so much for watching and until
next time see ya Space Cowboys